[Music]
that's what i was saying that you looked
like
when you turned when we turned like this
the lights on before we had that kind of
like oh yeah lighting right and then we
turned the lights on and i was like you
do look like one of those dudes at the
beginning of tick tock that was like you
know from arkansas that was like dressed
up like a vampire
they do that posing to like voiceovers
yeah don't [ __ ] with me
don't
you don't know what the beast is like
after nine o'clock
damn i found another tick tock and i
meant to screenshot some of the comments
it was like it was that meme from a
while back of like people commenting
like millennials or like horny
millennial moms like oh my god don't let
my husband see this
it was a [ __ ] it was just like it was
just someone getting bombed with those i
was
in tears oh my god if my husband knew
how [ __ ] wet i am right now and like
american flag emojis
i hate that [ __ ]
my for you page on tick tock is just
bottom barrel of consciousness it is
[ __ ] 8 iq behavior dude it's all just
meme edits
it's all just cake
[Applause]
[Music]
in a while
i finally figured out the sound
[Music]
[Laughter]
youtube search want a break from the oh
and i just want to see how you think you
should spell that it's a guy snoring
that's i don't know if i said that in
the last one but it's a dude snoring yep
[Music]
if you're on audio i'm sorry
wanna break from the
if you tap now to watch a short
you'll receive 30 minutes of
yes really if you now to watch a short
you'll receive 30 minutes of
you'll receive 30 minutes
you'll receive 30
minutes that's what it is all right now
play the original lovely the
[Music]
this original is snoring bro
he's just in the original he just laid
flat and his roommate walks in he just i
gotta see the original
i don't think
there's no one i don't think you can
find where did you see it dude i came
across it it had like you know like
maybe 500 000 likes i'm like this is
gonna be one of those that's like 50
million likes
is it on tick tock yeah but it's not on
youtube oh look at the [ __ ] um
doge underscore g compilation spock and
i were watching this in the studio the
other day
and we had to stop like i legitimately
was gonna pass out
that's too fast it dude
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
do the snore sound again
[Music]
my [ __ ] brain is broken this is my
whole 4u page the thing about his edits
i realized is he does not let you get a
chance that's what kills me
like you like you want to laugh
and it's already on to the next see
that's why these give you brain rot and
smooth your brain
is because you're it's you have to think
so [ __ ] hard that it every time you
see a meme like that it removes a ridge
from your brain yo 100 dude it just
moves it over because there's so many
like neurotransmitters like trying to
pass information to make sense of it
it's like your brain basically says
there's not enough time between the
punchline and the setup anymore yeah
that we should just be laughing at
everything yeah yeah because it's too
hard yeah like the the gap has gotten
too small exactly let's just laugh
consistently and it's just
my friend
i had to share a bed with my friend when
i was in cabo
and uh